MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Augmented reality
helps people experience digital
information in a new way.
Join us as we to talk to
Torch about how they're
enabling anyone to
build AR experiences
on this episode of Stack Chat.
Thanks for joining us, Josh.
Tell us a little bit more
about what Torch does.
JOSH FAUST: Thanks
for having me, Mark.
Torch is an AR design
and publishing platform.
So we are a mobile
first workflow
for building AR inside of AR.
We let designers very
quickly prototype and develop
augmented reality
experiences they can then
share with other people.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what
does the architecture
look like for
people who are going
to go in and build an AR app?
JOSH FAUST: So we had three main
goals when building Torch 1.0.
We wanted the camera first,
mobile first workflow.
We wanted to allow people to
easily bring in whatever assets
they had whether it's images,
video, 3D models, all of that.
And then we wanted to
enable collaboration
and semi-realtime collaboration
between users on the platform.
So we went with Firebase for the
mobile device portion of that
because it allowed us to
not really pay attention
to a lot of what we needed
to do to offload computation
into the Cloud.
Working on a mobile
device, we're already
very limited with CPU and GPU.
We're running computer
vision to do AR,
we're running realtime
3D rendering at 60 frames
a second.
So we needed to be able to
shift some of that computation
into the Cloud.
And Firebase lets
us do that really
easily by calling
Cloud Functions,
by using realtime
databases, things like that.
For Asset import,
we wanted to be
able to support all
sorts of file types
and to do it in a very
fast and efficient manner.
And so we did that
through a combination
of Firebase Functions and GKE.
So rather than trying to do
any kind of computationally
expensive processing
on the mobile device,
we ship Assets to
the Cloud, run them
through a Cloud
processor in GKE,
and then ship them
back into Functions
where we then update Firestore.
And that lets the mobile device
know that everything's ready.
Some examples of what
we do in the Cloud
are encoding images
into GPU formats.
We do model conversions between
various 3D file formats.
We process video for
realtime, things like that.
And then for collaboration,
we are really
leaning heavily on Firestore.
So we use realtime
snapshotting in order
to let multiple
clients be writing
to the same set of
documents and realtime
update everything that's
happening as it's happening.
We do this a little
bit differently
than you might think.
So we're not using single
documents as a document store.
We're doing time series data.
And what's awesome
is as events sourcing
where every event that has
ever happened in a project,
we know and we track.
And then to build
up the final result,
you run through every event
and generate the full scene
document or the full
project document.
And then for performance
and bandwidth reasons,
every once in a while
in a Cloud Function,
we will what we call
checkpoint those events.
And so that takes those events
up until a certain time,
turns it into the
final project format.
And so then to
retrieve a project,
we retrieve the
latest checkpoint
in any event that
has happened since.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
it sounds like a lot
of the realtime
collaboration, of course,
depends on Firestore.
What made you choose
Firestore as the right way
to handle this?
JOSH FAUST: So we had two
main reasons for that.
Because we're
primarily a mobile app
and we didn't want to write any
Cloud infrastructure that we
didn't really need to, direct
access to the DBE from mobile
and from Cloud Functions
was really important to us.
On the other side
of that, that's
a really double edged
sword because it
means that you need to be
really careful about your schema
management and making sure that
you're not doing anything bad
on either side of those.
And so what we ended up doing
is building a type safe layer
in TypeScript for access to
the database that makes sure
that programmers are
not willy nilly adding
to the schema, changing things
when we don't know about it.
And then we've also added the
ability to version and document
and migrate between versions.
So the second reason
we chose Firestore
is due to that snapshotting that
I talked about earlier where
we can just set up callbacks and
get live data as things change.
And it's just really easy
to hook into UI, to hook
into application state.
And so it just-- it provides us
with a programming model that
makes all that really easy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it
sounds like you may have
made some changes over time.
If you could go back
and re-architect this
based on what you
learned over the process,
what would you do differently?
JOSH FAUST: So the
first thing is,
if we were to redo it
today, Cloud Run now exists.
And so a lot of what
we actually built up
in GKE to do Asset
processing we could
do without having to build
what we built in GKE.
And so we would probably
move as much of our--
as much of the code that is
in GKE and Cloud Functions
into Cloud Run.
But it didn't exist at
the time, so oh, well.
The second thing is
schema management.
The schema that we
first chose for Assets
made it very expensive
for us to determine,
does a user have
access to this Asset?
And so what we've ended up with
is, in order to security store
Assets but also
make it very cheap
for users, for clients to
access any information they need
to download in Asset, we do
real time syncing of Asset data
into the project.
So any information that
a client needs in order
to recreate the project gets
mirrored into the project
itself.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks for telling us
about how you actually
built this application
to help other people build
their own applications.
JOSH FAUST: Absolutely.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Get
started with Cloud Firestore
by checking out this
quick start guide.
Thanks for watching.
And make sure to subscribe
for more great Google Cloud
Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on Stack Chat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]